i didn't know a dairy accent first off  and then i thought who do i know and  then i thought oh nadine from girls  aloud is extremely dairy and then i  don't know if people will know this but  there was an extremely controversial  incident  in the early 90s in ireland so good it  was so good it was the first irish sort  of pop culture tv moment it was pop  stars the irish version which only had  about 50 entrants because we don't have  as big a population um so she went on  and lied about her age but she got found  out on camera stop it yeah  okay so she's gotten into the band and  then her on camera interview like the  first one to introduce yourself who you  are she said madame is the dean coyla  from lark hill and he did a birth 15th  to 6 85 making me a gemini and then she  thinks for a second and goes what did  her birthday say you know 15 to the  second and then it fades  and she's she's outed herself on camera